does society need more billionaires
the society need more billionaires well
because there's plenty of people saying
it we need less the left maybe yeah I
don't know about that that's you know
there's this prevailing notion that you
that you can take the wealth of the
richest people in the world if you took
the wealth of the most successful
billionaires out there
put it in a big pile and then divided it
amongst the population
I have a strong suspicion that that
wealth would find its way back in the
pockets of the billionaires that you
stole it from probably within about four
or five years most of it anyway so I
think that's that's a delusional concept
that you know billionaires are bad and
you have to steal their wealth and you
have to redistrate so so there's that
um do we need good billionaires yeah we
need more Elon musks of the world I
think we need less Bill Gates and a lot
more Elon musks I don't think Bill Gates
has done anything productive for the
world aside from Microsoft what he's
done in the last few years with uh
contributions to the whole scandemic
thing I'm not pleased with that guy I
think he's I think he's a Menace to
Society at this point and he should just
retire and leave economics alone and
culture and everything else alone he's
buying he's he's he's the largest land
holder now in the United States Farmland
holder independent Farmland holder he's
bought up that much Farmland over the
last number of years so I don't know
what this guy's plans are but we need
good billionaires we need more Elon Musk
of the world unless the Bill Gates
is there not an argument that Bill Gates
has done a lot for various
um diseases and reducing them I don't
think so no what has he done
apparently almost single-handedly
reduced polio to virtually nothing
I've not seen that in my backyard no all
I've seen is what he's done with this
last scandemic and how he played such a
strong role in the vaccination protocols
the encouragement that everybody takes
it the you know the mandates the
lockdowns he was he was part and parcel
of a lot of those things with fauci and
all the other world leaders that
subscribe to the to the new world order
that they were trying to purport so
um I'm not familiar with anything he's
done with polio but then again I've not
seen polio in my lifetime
why do you think that Bill Gates didn't
just stick to Tech
well he made such a vast fortunate and
it seems like his
um
you know his his position in the company
ran its course they didn't need him and
I think at some point as an entrepreneur
you get bored of your business too don't
you
um you know I I ran my debt settlement
business for 12 15 years before I
realized that I think I've had enough
you know I want to move on to some other
things so
I I don't see a lot of large
you know billion dollar companies
keep the founder around for a lifetime
it doesn't seem to happen very often I'm
sure at some point Elon Musk will find a
way to release himself of his duties to
Twitter and Tesla and the like as well
and focus on other projects that are
going to demand more of his time
and why do you prefer someone like Elon
Musk over someone like Bill Gates
well he's solving real problems that
matter you know like one of the things
that I
that I admire him for and he's not a
perfect man like I've I've certainly
criticized Elon Musk over the years too
but
you know for for us to survive as a
species
we're gonna have to be multi-planetary
right if there's a giant meteor or a
rock or a comet or something that's
finding its way towards Earth that's an
extinction level type of event if it's
big enough and it's going to wipe out a
good chunk of the population so he's
doing things for the betterment of
humanity uh neuro link is another
project that he's working on which he
gets some criticism for but I think the
the inherent Baseline nature of what
he's trying to use that for is going to
improve lives as well uh I'm not sold on
the whole electric car thing I'm still a
big petrol head and I like the internal
combustion engine but I see where it's
going and I actually prefer the
electrification of petroleum-powered
cars so there's that that seems to be
working but yeah I think overall he's
he's contributing net positive to
society if I can put it that way
do you think we have free speech in the
world right now no
why not absolutely not
um we have some platforms that are
improving that like with what musk has
done with Twitter again that's that's a
positive contribution that I see him
making to society uh I've seen enough
evidence since he's taken the reins of
that business in which he's exposed what
happened during the last election how
Twitter was used to manipulate US during
the scandemic
um you don't have free speech generally
speaking on most platforms I've been
um
there's certain things that I can't say
and do on YouTube you know for example
which I could say and do on another
platform maybe like Rumble you know for
example so you cannot speak as if you
and I were sitting in a pub having a
pint just having a a conversation you
have to change the conversation when you
broadcast on their platform because at
the end of the day it's their platform
and they get to decide whether or not
you get to say or do certain things on
it even though it's your content
why do you think people men like Andrew
Tate and Jordan Peterson have become so
viral let's say
I think it's an absence of fathers in
the household to be honest with you and
in some cases it's it's fathers that
have been pushed out of the household by
difficult mothers in some cases they're
just loser fathers that shouldn't have
been fathers to begin with OR they were
like pieces of furniture in the
household but either way there's there's
the removal of strong conventional
masculine men in the household so you've
got this generation of rudderless young
boys and men that are looking for
somebody to look up to and a Jordan
Peterson when he says something like
stand up straight clean your room
um and you know speak with some
confidence for example gets the
attention right when a guy like Andrew
Tate a big strong kickboxer with a bunch
of fast cars and beautiful women speaks
he's going to get the attention of young
impressionable men that are looking to
replicate that that want the fast cars
the watches and the beautiful women
right so
there's a vacuum and it was it was
created by if you want to call it you
know the Matrix or whatever uh we we've
changed the dynamic in which children
grow up in households now dramatically
dramatically in in my grandfather's era
there was no divorce there was uh there
was always a father around you know he
was the authority in the household he
had responsibility to the household
along with authority in the household to
run it as he saw fit generally speaking
you don't have
Authority anymore in a household as a
man you have responsibility as you
always did but they've Stripped Away the
authority and isn't that the very
definition of slavery losing your
Authority but having responsibility so
you've got a lot of these young men
today that are looking for guidance
they're looking for a strong masculine
role model you're attracted to that I I
remember vividly as a child watching
things like Conan the Barbarian and
Conan the Destroyer and thinking wow
that's impressive I want to look like
that guy when I get older right and I
had a father in the household
right so the absence of having the
father means that you're going to be
seeking these strong Alpha type of men
because you because it's like Gravity
Man it just sucks you into them right
just like a beautiful woman sucks you
into their gravity a strong virtuous man
that looks like he's doing something
with his life and is competent and is
influential and is interesting will get
the attention of other people and that's
what Peterson and Tate you know offer
and do you think Andrew Tate Jordan
Peterson their net benefit for Humanity
I believe so absolutely I mean I
wouldn't listen to Jordan Peterson when
it comes to advice on Love and Marriage
um one of the things that he
disappointed me in was that he published
this uh three-part series I think was on
daily wire on marriage and I thought
well that was interesting because I
followed him for a while I have a
chapter in my book on why smart men
avoid marriage so I wanted to hear what
he had to say on it so I subscribed and
I listened to it and it's like it was
all just man up don't be a wimp get
married you know do it in front of a
church and the other people you love you
know you just can't date a woman you
just can't live with a woman it's
degenerate
um blah blah blah sort of thing so I
wouldn't listen to Jordan Peterson when
it comes to marriage advice because
there was nothing in there about hey uh
does she have the bright Triad you know
features of good woman uh does she have
a personality disorder uh is she a
single mom with four kids from three
different fathers like there's there's
things that you need to contemplate
before before you invite marriage into
your life if you want to have an uh
a fun and easy marriage or fun and easy
relationship you know with a woman so I
think he misses the boat in certain
areas the same thing with Tate like I
don't agree with everything that Andrew
says I like the guy I think he's funny I
would love to do a Supercar rally with
him of course but does he get everything
right no I don't think so but I think
he's a force generally speaking for good
for a minute for men and women actually
you know if I can put it that way I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out